welcome to this video playing ceases
ceases from Finland the shop h fry
that's a very rare line because of
exactly this what what we have on the
board it's um it leads to completely
wacky play but play that it's not
believed to be very good for black f or
white I'm sorry not sure I'm playing it
in the most precise manner but let's see
the blood the dark squared weaknesses
are the issue okay now still I can maybe
take him maybe just go in before trying
to get get Queens off on yeah any Queen
trade should be fine for me long term
with the dark squared weaknesses and the
two bishops am I'm perfectly fine even
if I lose the the h4 pond that's no
problem at all okay we have the Queen
trade 95 s the is the real issue here
the this type of irritating look at that
might put my position into some disarray
okay so he just gives me this pawn
trying to speed up inside evelopment
okay i will take it and go from them 95
interesting position still now what I
don't don't believe in it much for
whiter it's not it's not like totally
totally crazy 95 there should be six my
idea giving away the bishop or quite ok
but material wise i have a pawn more
even at the moment it's not a great porn
but if you place 95 to should be six and
takes it a BF rook fif coming attacking
the brick e5 pawn so I don't mind that
so much okay so no way i can actually
take you five or is I don't get it
really yeah I will take it come on
rookie one I have to ship ef-2 anyway
everything else fails I have that
and 95 this should be six still should
be fine
yeah it's notoriously tricky in this
position you can also okay here we
should have to William yeah but what is
the threat way or 97 year okay that's
obvious but what is happening if I go
kinky aid some play g3 mmm maybe
rook g5 maybe rope 254 smooth is it
taking here both porns but I can go to
the second rank
remarkable play really I'm here here
take and he takes age 70 so at the end
we haven't have equal material and I buy
a new station to Bishop t5 no yeah great
okay black resigned yeah I don't really
know i mean the h porn is probably
giving what's emerged yet but not like i
should use probably a question is how to
exactly play it I don't airman connect
to e6 that's the lab it's a little bit
slow maybe okay I can prepare it with
rock he ate something like that yeah
white is definitely better with the edge
porn much better so the whole the whole
procedure wasn't good I wonder in him
because here i should i should be better
that that's quite obvious also i will
get it I get in five and I have two
bishops and so on I mean there should be
something should be for a slow computer
choice getting the pawn that way now
that that really makes some sense i mean
something like this i will keep the
bishop that this is a yeah this is
really good for black so I'm not not the
way and if he goes here I'll take with
the bishop it's still it's still a bit a
bit murky here the computer gives black
just a pawn am just a pawn yeah it's
still it's still a bit tricky because I
like some coordination but it's very
better than the game here this the
sativa tea with rook age 5 is some quite
a problem yeah maybe I should go to f5
air to f8 instead of d 8
this is probably an idea now I can also
move the bishop here and it's it's it's
getting tricky in here is better with
this Bishop c4 and we should have seven
business why do we end this is of course
a fantastic move alright thanks for
watching